hi everyone as as mentioned my name is
Sarah Dresner I'm if I apologize if I'm
coughing a little bit I don't wear
glasses but I'm very nerdy so I have
asthma so if I COFF a little bit while
I'm speaking that is why I am a
consultant this isn't a picture of me
and my mom and also my relationship to
Authority I'm a consultant and I used to
be a manager of UX design and
engineering at trulia zillow group and
now I give talks and I work for
companies all over the place and give
workshops speaking about things like I'm
going to speak about today so before we
get into any details about animation I
think it's important that we start from
the beginning what happens when you
visit a website every time you look at a
picture or anytime you look at a website
at all your eye isn't looking directly
at anything your eye is gonna constantly
move around an event called saccade and
the part of the reason why we do this
and these are heat maps of where your
eyes are looking part of the reason we
do this is to create a spatial awareness
of the site or of the thing that we're
looking at you do this so that you can
kind of understand your surroundings
biologically but it works the same way
on a website so why is this important
like why are we talking about the way
that our eyes look around and see these
things we already use this information
all the time web sites all start to look
the same because you get used to like
having the CTA on the right and having
the big hero image and stuff so people
feel comfortable when they come to their
site their know their way around they
don't have to kind of grok all of the
information that you're giving them at
once they can kind of already know what
they're supposed to be clicking and
hitting in order to engage buttons on a
website and CTAs become the most
powerful thing we tend to like make
everything else grey or green or blue
and then these like bright orange CTA so
that our users know where to click
because when they're gay
gathering all of that spatial awareness
looking around the site they can say Oh
aha like that is the piece that I need
right there this is also why things like
growth hacking happen and people are
like okay making the button purple like
it make it pop polka dot make it pulse
and like developers are like no so
that's why that kind of stuff happens
that's also why we have all these like
user testings to see what will work this
way or that way when you're scanning and
reading things what actually draws your
eye and because of this animation kind
of gets a bad rap because when you're
scanning an environment and something is
moving that is the most powerful thing
you are biologically programmed to
notice and take note of something that's
in motion if you do animation well it
can be really really an informative
experience and guide your users in a
really important way but if you do
animation poorly then it could be
irritating and jostling for the user so
in light of that let's talk about
animation in terms of how you can create
spatial awareness 'iz and be responsible
for your users and part of the way that
we're gonna do that is we're gonna
separate out to ideas and animation one
of them is invisible animation or ui/ux
animation and the other is immersive
animation so we're gonna speak about
those two things totally differently
because they're they're in essence
totally different ideas when you're
talking about invisible animation the
whole purpose of it is so that the user
is not thinking like oh I just had an
animation happen what they're thinking
is what it like a cohesive experience I
just had when you're doing an immersive
animation the whole point is to guide
the user through like an entire idea of
animation and we'll kind of dig into
each one of these things in in a lot of
detail but let's start with invisible
animation what I mean by that so UX
animation and UX choreography kind of
come together in this format so when
we're creating these mental maps a lot
of times when we're dealing with stuff
on a website the most challenging thing
that we have is state right that's
something that we work a lot with in
terms of like moving over
to react to manage state or like
understanding state as we manage it in
the Dom or understanding how the things
change and shift and move as a user
engages with our site so when you're
when your users are working with your
site and they're totally getting into it
and they're having this like flow based
experience because everything is really
really groovy and then all of a sudden
you interrupt them with like a modal or
something that's kind of just jarring
and jostling and doesn't work for your
experience it can completely destroy
what you've built for them this you
spent so much time creating these mental
maps for them and spatial awareness for
them and then all of a sudden you break
it that's bad
so we're connecting to different states
like we are here so you know a very
small example of this would be like the
one on the left where things kind of
just jump into view and the one on the
right where you kind of get a sense of
where things are coming from and where
they're going in like where the spatial
awareness is there so Kathy Sierra has
this awesome book called badass making
users awesome and a good talk that's
associated with it
and in it she kind of talks about these
cognitive leaks that can develop as we
structure our UIs and new X's so if
we're looking at something like this you
know burners that you might have on your
typical stovetop you have a bunch of
burners and then you have a bunch of
controls for the burners and you can see
here like it always takes me a second
like wait which knob is for which thing
but if you just restructure it a little
bit you can see how those cognitive
leaks are reduced you all of a sudden
just by rearranging those things are
giving users much more of a key for how
they should be working with your site so
I made this pen to kind of demonstrate
this idea so if I have this map marker
and I open it and then in that this
contact form because actually I should
probably turn the brightness up sorry I
was on an airplane that contact form
becomes the title and then the email
gets out of the way and then when I hit
the submit button
those two things become the loader which
then in turn becomes the success well
the things go on in the background and
then I know what what happened and what
is where it's going and where it's
coming from now when I close that down
it becomes the Mack marker again and if
I said to you later
where did it go where is the contact
form you would say oh it's in there
there's no in there
they're all just divs they've just
absolutely positioned things and stuff
all of that is just like CSS and stuff
like that but really what it does for
the user is it gives them a sense of
spatial awareness and what happened was
we went through three different screens
of cognitive and mental maps that you
would have had to create and instead of
making that again and again with like
successive modal's or successive
dialogues we have it all one fluid
experience it feels much better for the
user so it can happen in these small
ways too you don't have to do something
as big as that either this is a kind of
typical UX pattern right we've got like
you know simple like magnifying icon and
then when I click on it it becomes the
input and what's nice about this is when
I put it away it not only does it give
us that spatial awareness of like oh it
goes in there and make it feel a uniform
it also takes up a lot less space in our
interface right we don't have the entire
giant like the magnifying glass the
input the submit button all of those
things we can actually condense those
things down and make a better experience
for the user
another thing that's important is
isolation so if I have like in that same
way if I'm like scanning my environment
and I'm trying to make create a mental
map of a situation if I have to read a
lot of information at once it takes me a
lot of time it takes me if there's more
cognitive leaks in that idea so if I
like zoom in on one of these it all of a
sudden becomes much more easy to read
and for me to understand and like really
really process that information it's not
a lot more things at all to build that
in so I was thinking about this idea of
revealing and
how much I hate modal's I just hate
modal's it's like a weird personal
vendetta thing but it's not actually
even super personal in that Google hates
them too and has started to dock you
points if you have timed interstitials
on mobile so if you are one of those
companies that waits a few seconds and
then Springs a modal on you when you
look at a site Google is now gonna take
off SEO points so you should not do that
so I'm not the only one who has this
vendetta I I think that that is a really
jarring experience it breaks your
context you're like involved in
something and without triggering
anything this thing pops up and I would
call that kind of like brute force UX
you know you're like I want the user to
see this stick it in their face which is
not you know the most intelligent way of
working with the web so this is me and
like a really detailed picture of me
very very highly proficient and drawing
modal's suck but then this is also me
thinking about it later
well okay wait let's be fair it's maybe
not just them it's their typical UX
pattern I bet that there is a way of
investigating a modal that makes it make
more sense and makes it not break all of
these things that you set up for
yourself so rather than have it be x and
just like an attack you would have to
open it you would have you as the user
would have to engage in order to create
it but it comes from that button and
because it comes from that button I know
where it came from and I know where it's
going and it doesn't feel as jarring
anymore
sometimes I dismiss modal's right away
when they pop up even if I need that
information so in this way I can get it
again if I decide that I need it and I
know where it's coming from and I know
where to retrieve it so I was thinking
about this this whole idea like the
whole idea of how we have to bake
animation into an experience and that
animation can't just be slapped on on
top right like some of the examples that
I just showed you particularly like that
contact form one I couldn't have just
added animation at the end and that's
the way that a lot of PM's and a lot of
companies kind of deal with animation
they're like okay
let's just build the page and we'll slap
the animation on after but it really
needs to be part of the core experience
otherwise for the user it feels like an
extra thing they're waiting for so I was
considering this as I was in Barcelona
this summer and I was on this trip and I
was on this trip exploring a city and I
wanted to build out a day of activities
so this is kind of like a normal use
case I love Lonely Planet and it has
really good content but if I go here and
then there's like five steps to even get
to Barcelona and then there I came from
there I can scroll down and see the
sights but like okay so that's good I
have some content that like helps me
find something I'm gonna pick la Sagrada
família I hear that's pretty nice and I
look there and this is the map that they
have is like the site and then one thing
that's a pub and then one thing that's
like another Church but like what if I
want to get lunch and what if I want to
see another site you can't expand this
map at all or like engage with it
so then I go back and then all of a
sudden the sites look different and and
then I scroll down to food and drink
which also looks totally different I
have to scan and create a new
environment but then at the very bottom
of the page there's this map section I'm
like okay that's maybe that's better so
I have this sites but all it has those
sites so if I go to if I click on each
one it takes me to the page of la
Sagrada família takes me back this isn't
great I'd have to keep writing down
where I'm going I need food all sorts of
stuff so Google Maps kind of does
something that's similar but different
in its better right so we once I have la
Sagrada família like it won't suggest to
me to go to a lesser Cara familia but
once I know I'm gonna go there I can
click here and it says like search
nearby which is pretty great because I
can look for restaurants that are nearby
that area that's getting closer cool but
then you know if I want to look for bars
or pubs I lose all the context of all of
the restaurants that I was just at so
that's not so good and I can send it to
my phone but then I'm sending each fun
off to my phone so I was kind of canned
they also have things like reviews but
their content
unlike long
planet is not so great so let's consider
how animation can really help the user
and here like let's empower the user so
I built this demo which hopefully loads
so if you type in love for the Sagrada
família you go to sites then you're
going in between the sites and you can
kind of go through them and then you can
pick one and then you can pick food and
you can go the food and I could keep
going and pick more sites or I could
just pick the itinerary that I want and
send the whole thing to my phone that's
more what I want that's more what I need
as a user and in this animation isn't
like hi I'm animation look at me go in
this animation is key and core to the
experience but that's not the only thing
that's key in court of the experience
you're really thinking about the whole
thing from start to finish for the user
and not just what features you have but
what they are looking for and what they
want to make so like we can just empower
them in this way and that's a really
really awesome thing that we can do so a
piece of tough love here for everybody
who works on the web because I hear a
lot of hate for animation
do you hate animation if animation feels
like the sugar on top that might be
because you treated it that way so like
if you are one of those companies who
said okay let's wait until we have the
whole thing built and then we're gonna
put some animation on on top that is an
additive experience that is not core to
the experience that you're giving your
users that's something that you're doing
just to delight yourself which you know
delight is great but it's not
informative and animation can be
informative which is some of its power
so things to keep in consideration when
you're working with your own company's
animation as you're like we'll take
these lessons and learn from them and
want to engage and put them into your
site style and branding in animation is
just as important as style and branding
in like text or color and things that we
kind of consider often for other kinds
of things like if we hadn't done this
with text already I'd be
here talking about text if we hadn't
done it with color I'd be talking about
color but I think animation needs a hero
so we have these kind of like if you all
over your site you have these like
linear eases you can have a conformation
that's like a bounce and then all of a
sudden people on the your users are like
oh that was a little bit different maybe
I need to be paying attention to that I
guess that was a success screen so you
can use animation and like different
kinds of entrances and exits to really
call meaning there's also like this
thing called react motion that's really
awesome what it does is it allows you to
vana mayshen one of them and that that
we're gonna go into like more detail
about today it's going to be about
sequential based animation timed
animation that you're probably more
familiar with react motion is very
different it's like game based animation
it allows you to have physics and mass
and put that on the object and then you
send it on its way so it's interruptible
it's good for things like chat heads and
things like that
so that you can like actually have the
user engage with it at that moment so
we'll talk a little bit about tools but
the way that these things are moving
around is nine-tenths of the law
if they were just scooting over that
wouldn't be the same experience at all
but but because I'm playing around with
the way that those easing --zz work with
the way that those Springs work that
makes the whole animation experience
feel different and that's part of your
branding as well so if we're looking at
these two balls everybody has to do a
bouncy ball demo like if you are an
animator like you're just like you sit
down and then somebody comes into the
room and they say it's time for the
bouncy ball demo and then you have to
write it so this is my bouncy ball demo
the one one of these balls feels a
little bit more rigid and feels a little
bit harder and the other ball feels a
little bit more fluid and it's subtle
right it's not like over-the-top or
anything but these have the exact same
timings and the exact same heights and
they don't even feel like it they feel
like they have different timings they
feel like they have different structures
they feel like they're going to
different heights because of the way
that they're animating and so that
becomes really really important
a one last thing to say about style and
branding if you are the kind of person
who has a site like fidelity insurance
where you have like a bunch of money and
you're dealing with somebody's cash you
might want to be dealing with like more
responsible linear eases and like maybe
the hardball is like your ball but if
you're something like MailChimp that has
branding that's really playful and
engaging and exciting you might want to
step away from that and make something
that's a little bit more bouncy and a
little bit more fluid so all of the ways
that you work with those so you'd have
the bouncy ball on the ride for sure
so with these kind of anticipatory cues
if I have this form here and I'm
actually let's open it up in its own
page so if I have this form here and I
write my email blah blah blah and a lot
of times what will happen is when you
have a form and you submit something
into a form you're giving your
information to a website and that's kind
of a you know not so great experience
for the user
you have to let them know that something
is going on while you're doing that like
just having the submit button and then
letting them sit there and wait while
something happens - for a database in
the background is kind of harrowing for
them so if I hit this contact button and
it becomes a loader it you know feels a
little bit more fluid and that actually
took some time but I didn't feel that
time passing as well as much and I'm not
sitting there like United Airlines did
you take my money or not I don't know I
also like let them know with a big
bright green success screen that
something good happened here that's
great you are okay why don't you go
somewhere else in our site now so I'm
thinking about that whole fluid
experience going to another thing you
don't need to make it so big or anything
but just letting them know that
something good happened you want them to
feel good things like dopamine when
they're on your site you want them to
feel successful when they're on your
site so this is part of perceived
performance you might have heard of
perceived performance - this is like a
really big strength of animation so
anticipate anticipatory queues these
custom loaders biet did an experiment
and
that when you use like an old-timey
loader that everybody's seen before
people are not willing to wait as long
if just that that we get logo with the
tiny little dots that's not a crazy kind
of animation that's not like a an insane
thing to implement but people were
willing to wait twice as long for that
loader because you tell the customer
hey we care about you we made something
for you hold on a minute and that really
actually means a lot to the user with
all of these experiments that we're
doing another thing that's kind of nice
is if you have these perceived
performances that aren't just like out
of the box if you do something that's a
little bit more unusual it captures
their attention and that also doesn't
feel as long that doesn't make you feel
like you're waiting forever and it's an
amazing amazing how a few seconds it
takes a user to feel like you ditched
them so so even just thinking about a
small animation like this that really
doesn't take you like if you're using
something like gzip which we'll talk
about in a second this is one line of
code that can actually really change the
way that your user is feeling about the
way that you feel about them so one of
the big takeaways here spatial awareness
is important we're trying not to break
spatial awareness because we don't want
to let our users down and you know don't
draw people and stuff so you know and
like when we're creating and using these
kind of spatial awareness techniques we
can go from simple like we were talking
about here to more complex this was a
code drops demo so if you want to select
your seats at this theater you can see
how just with like a little bit of
animation you're actually letting you're
telling the user so much more about what
this experience is gonna feel like for
them when they're in the theater and how
that's going to be for them and it's a
much much more engaging experience than
them just selecting their seats we can
also do something simple and small like
these drag and drop in interactions so
if I've got like these kind of things
where I've got to like hold a piece of
information for the
again if I asked somebody where did that
go you would say it went down there if
there's no down there it's a absolutely
position div but like knowing that they
know where to get it and they know where
it went is really helpful for them they
didn't have to break any kind of spatial
awareness for that so we can't really
talk about animation without talking
about performance performance is really
important because when things look janky
and things like stutter across the
screen even if you have the most
beautiful animation in the world people
are going to not feel so great about it
so one thing that's really important is
that you're using opacity and transforms
wherever possible you can do crazy
amazing stuff with just opacities and
transforms it's amazing what you can
accomplish so I know it sounds like two
properties that doesn't sound like much
but you can actually accomplish a ton of
things you should also be thinking about
hardware acceleration things like this
translate see hack you can even make a
mixin for it that you can apply or an
extend where you can apply it all over
the code base so you don't sorry write
it all of the time so let's take a look
at what that would look like so for this
pen we've got like a hardware
accelerated div moving across and a
control so this is the the like margin
I'm moving things with margins for this
one and I'm moving things with
transforms for this one I'm not sure if
you can see from that screen but on my
screen the top one is flickering and
kind of moving across in a really janky
way well the bottom one is moving very
very beautifully across now also if you
look in chrome dev tools and I say
something like alright let's go to more
tools and we're gonna go to rendering
I'm gonna pull this up and I'm gonna say
paint flashing when you when you use
paint flashing in the chrome dev tools
what's gonna be highlighted in that
green is anything that you're moving
around whether it's causing repaints so
you can immediately see anything that's
on your screen that you're not really
dealing with correctly so that's a
really nice visual cue if you're doing
an audit of a bunch of animations at
once saying okay we need help here and
we need
help here and we need help here in case
you were wondering if it's just me who
thinks this Netflix also employs all of
these things you can read a case study
about that
yeah they work with opacity and
transforms in order to animate some of
the very simple hover effects that they
have on their movies so all of that said
we kind of went into all of these like
how to really subtly deal with you know
your spatial awareness and your users
and getting them from here to there now
let's kind of break and talk about
something else and it's similar but
different in its immersive animation so
immersive animation would be a little
bit closer to like if you have a diagram
that you're trying to like show
something to the user explain a concept
you're not trying to hide the animation
from them that whole experience is
supposed to be an animation or like if
you think about like the big movie sites
where they're like the whole idea is
just like go watch Life of Pi and here
are lions and tigers and things so
that's an immersive animation they're
not trying to like subtly do anything
they're just like we're gonna wow you so
this is a different type of animation
and a different we deal with it in a
different way the purpose is to call
attention and I there's lots of
different ways of working with them 3je
yes and canvas and there's be our
experiences but today we're gonna focus
on SVG because I think it's a little bit
closer to what we were dealing with
before in that the typical you know web
developer will probably be able to work
with it and create something really
beautiful and it's got a lot of things
going for it one of them is that it's
got really great support SVG like has
kind of a bad reputation for not being
well supported I do consulting work with
a lot of different companies and one of
the first things they say to me is
always like oh well but SVG isn't
supported but look at all that green I
think it kind of crept up on us we have
this like old idea that it has poor
support but it doesn't anymore
so we should take advantage of that you
probably know these things already but
I'm just going to go over them just
really quickly to talk about some of the
things I love about SVG it's crisp on
every any display for anybody who's had
do like image replacement for retina and
things like that you don't have to slice
a million images the picture element is
great but you still have to make all of
these different images and cut them all
up and you know make sure that they're
all like working properly and your
polyfill is working properly you don't
have to do that with SVG you have one
graphic because of that there's less
HTTP requests to handle and in some
cases no requests to handle because you
can have it in line and then you're not
making any requests at all and the thing
that's the fastest request is no
requests so it's also easily scalable
for responsive we're gonna talk about
that a bit that's probably one of my
favorite parts of this and that's
probably part part of the reason why it
has gotten so much giant popularity
lately
that's a really really important one and
it can be a really small file size if
you design for performance
if you design for performance is a
really important concept here not all
designs are gonna be created equal you
can't just like throw massive things in
there it's built with math which is
really awesome you can do such crazy
things with it and very unique things
with it but if you load it up it's not
like a bitmap where you're just like
pixel pixel pixel pixel you have to pay
attention to what you're actually
putting in there it offers a navigable
Dom which is super awesome because it's
easy to animate you already know the Dom
adding a class to something and then
animating it is stuff that you already
know you don't have to learn any new
material in order to animate pieces of
an SVG and it's easy to make accessible
how cool is that you can have a creative
crazy immersive experience with data
visualization and lots of information
and it can be accessible to screen
readers that's one of my favorite parts
like you no longer just have these
images with alt tags you can actually
have them looking for bits that you want
them to or go over the whole thing if
you don't want them to so you know I
hear a lot of times people say like
flash is dead but we really miss it and
well you know I kind of think SVG
animation is more fun than Flash I I
think like people kind of got stuck in
the like oh flash was so good at all
lista but there's so many capabilities
that we have now with SVG animation that
people haven't even tapped into so what
is it good for it's good for interactive
and immersive animations it's good for
narrative it's good for UI UX animations
like the ones that you just saw like
that morphing pin it's great for
prototyping because it's easy like the
designer gives you a sketch in that
sketch is the webpage that's great and
it's really awesome for data
visualizations because it's built with
math so if we're looking at this pen in
terms of narrative
there's a lot that you can do just with
one image and picture and just by moving
some text around in terms of
communicating a story and in terms of
making an engaging experience for the
user actually Sarah Sweden showed this
my demo I had a conference and then she
was like oh how many introverts are out
there raise your hand and like nobody so
hmm what's really really cool about it
too is that it can be responsive so if
I'm gonna do like a book of Kelly I
don't know if you any of you have heard
of book of kells so these beautiful
illuminated manuscripts and they did
these like initial illustrations so they
take the first letter and they make it
kind of beautiful so I decided to make a
modern-day book of kells and so this
would be like the desktop version and
then this is the tablet version and then
this is the mobile version so you can
see it gets like less and less visually
complex and you know kind of adjusts to
each viewport in that way so that's the
design when I when I poured it over to
like create the actual SVG I make a
sprite out of it because I'm saying like
okay well I see some repeated things
between the like desktop and the tablet
version and I can just change the
background with a color change like just
a media query that's pretty easy I'll
slap some classes on some of the
repeated elements and I'll hide and
display them with media queries just the
way that we're used to and then I can
have this like this other piece and I'll
use the view box which is a really
awesome tool that SVG has to just hide
and display pieces of that sprite as it
changes so then I can have something
like this where it's like an animated
effects and it goes all the way down and
then we have this kind of book of kells
that changes and what's nice about this
is that whole animation and SVG
everything and the text was 8 kilobytes
gzipped so compare that to using text
and image to tell a story like big
photos that everybody is using all over
the place that are really huge
performance hits for websites you can
make something in
gauging informative interesting and that
can be in performance and you could be
accessible all of these things you don't
have to compromise anything I think a
lot of times when people see something
kind of interesting on the web they
think like oh we have to compromise
something in order to get there
you don't have to compromise anything so
we'll talk a little bit about green sock
I won't be able to go into tons of
detail because I don't have tons of time
but it's a really good tool for working
with SVG animation one of my favorite
reasons for working with green sock and
probably the reason why I talk about it
so much is because it's I don't work for
them by the way it's because it solves
cross browser inconsistencies there's a
lot of weirdnesses that you'll get in
Safari and especially Safari and Firefox
and stuff and this really really helps
solve all of those I still doesn't
support transforms on SVG ie get it
together seriously if you if you want to
go vote for this they'd like definitely
do I should have put a link to that in
the slides or something but definitely
go vote for support for transforms and
SVG it also offers a timeline which is
super great because you can stack tweens
you can set them a little before and
after one another
you can change their placement in time
you can group them into scenes you can
add relative labels you can animate your
animations and you can make the whole
thing faster and move the placement of
the whole thing and nest everything so I
think it is like an incredible tool for
animation and what's really nice about
it is you can do it without
recalculation
I love CSS and I did the last pen and
CSS but the issue with it is sometimes
these recalculations because like let's
say I have two animations that have to
fire at the same time and someone says
okay make that one a little bit smaller
and I have a bunch of delays after it I
have a bunch of chain defects I didn't
have to go back and figure out like all
redo all of the math for all of those
and figure out all the delays for both
and it's kind of a pain but in with gzip
and JavaScript it's a lot easier to work
with your you're changing one value
instead of 10 so anytime you're working
with like a small
bit of ui/ux animation I think CSS is
great anytime you have to chain
something or make something more complex
and you get beyond three chaining x' i
really suggest working working with
something like g sap and javascript so
we have this pen to kind of demonstrate
I'll actually open this in another
window so I made this like this kind of
animation and this one thing fires a few
times and it kind of goes around and
just to show you how the timeline works
I can call a function for that and then
I can call it repeated times on that
timeline and then I can have that like
first section and it goes here and then
I can have like that other section and
that's plotted to this point and the
timeline you can see it so I probably
don't need to narrate it for you but
it's kind of fun anyway so you have a
menu of this next section and it gets it
it's put here so I can actually just
then just change the order of them in
one line of code and have the whole
thing run in a different direction or I
could say okay it just wasn't fast
enough so I just want to make it a bunch
faster and in one line of code that's
like totally achievable so that's really
powerful and makes working with
animation a lot less tangled and
confusing so the other cool thing about
SVG is we can do fully fully scalable
and responsive stuff because you're what
you're doing is you're working within
the SVG Dom so even if you're plotting
with transforms it's working within that
SVG Dom structure so I can make this any
size and it's gonna stay totally stable
absolutely stable which is obviously
like really huge boon to responsive
development I can just keep replaying
this and making it different sizes
that's pretty cool
but you know our anime are like
interfaces aren't just squishy they
don't just like squish back and forth
but let's implement a bit of responsive
design here so if we design interactions
into responsive animations we're gonna
make a huggy laser panda Factory yes as
was mentioned before you know like you
have in real life
hardly Laser panda factories
so we have the desktop version here in
the mobile version here and you can see
that there's like different sections to
this so they're kind of like Legos
here's one here's another this one is
this one but it's just flipped around to
stack and then they kind of nest in
there and we have different timelines
and those timelines are scoped exactly
to those design pieces like Legos - so
our code is scoped like our design is
and if I have to adjust something I know
exactly where to go in that illustrator
document and I know exactly where to go
in my code it keeps everything really
nice and neat and organized and very
simple so if we have like this and we
have the factory so I click this and he
becomes like lasered and he's evil and
then we have this any beak-like becomes
a panda and then we do this and he's
like all of a sudden I'm very huggy and
I can scroll my browser window down and
it reconfigures and it still works
perfectly on mobile and this all was
like 12 kilobytes gzipped
so that's kind of fun and kind of
interesting and there's a lot of stuff
that we can do on the web that we have
not done yet that is really engaging and
exciting part of you know I mentioned
accessibility accessibility is a giant
thing here I could have like gone
through and labeled each one of the
things that I was just firing off and to
tell the story of the Panda to people
who need a screen reader I can also say
something like roll presentation and
have it skip over that whole SVG Dom if
you are gonna use things like titles do
remember to use things like IDs this
isn't just about SVG or anything that's
that's like an important thing for you
to note when you say Aria labeled by
title it's a lot easier for jaws and
NVIDIA to find the title here and it's
also important to have the language on
there too so that people in different
countries can actually have it be
translated so I'm not going to go into
giant details about accessibility again
because we don't have time but there's a
resource here with support charts and
this article by Heather is really really
awesome and
CSS tricks and she goes into like every
kind of SVG and how to make all of them
accessible so that's a really great
resource I think she went to the library
like every Sunday testing everything on
every device that she put a ton of time
and effort into it so you should
definitely use that resource and make
good use of it so I made a game we're
gonna play it real quick so there's this
elephant he's pretty good tacos but his
friends keep texting him to change plans
even though he just wants to tacos and
so you have to like play this game and
try not to get hit by the text messages
there's a margarita attitude so it's
based off of real-life events of this
hipster elephant and all of this was
built with SVG and react and you can
kind of see this like art leader up here
is gonna change as I get like more and
less and yeah if you lose you like you
become hangry and you have to go see a
movie that you've already seen before so
all of this stuff was created with web
technologies it was created with react
it was created with SVG and was created
with green sock how did we use SVG here
we used it three ways we did it just
directly in line for things that were
looping across we had things like
background images for stuff like the
tacos that we're gonna always stay the
same size and we had it in line and
react and I'll show you why we did
here's a heart meter even if you're not
familiar with react I'll walk you
through it's not gonna be a lot of code
here we have this thing called width in
this SVG for this rect and it's passing
down that's not prop score and what that
that this dot prop score is doing is
telling it what our score is and it's
gonna update that width so what's cool
about SVG since it's drawn with math is
that when you have something like a
rectangle all you have is a width a
height an X and a Y value so if I say
something like 250 for the width it
updates and makes the line longer that's
makes it really easy to work with and
just like update and change so that's
really really cool and that's why we can
use something like that very very easily
for the web how do we animate things we
animated them four ways we did G SAP
looping the green sock G stop looping
functions outside of react for like the
clouds and things we had
requestanimationframe to see if things
hit each other we had green sock for
keys app for key press events and those
key press events are just native key
press events and then we had a repeating
callbacks for the tacos and margaritas
you know your regular repeating taco
callback and we're just having it go
again and again so this is like a G SAP
function where when it finished
it's gonna pass those parameters again
so that they can move across the screen
again and the code is actually pretty
simple to create a fun game so this is
smoke with SVG I think I'm showing you
this because I think people tend to
think of SVG is only being these like
linear kind of like platonic shapes and
that you can't do a lot of like really
fun and beautiful things with it but
with things like filters and things like
gradients you can create really ethereal
and elemental effects Chris Chris here
in the audience invented SVG so he's
making faces at me right now you can
also make things like candles you can
make things morph and change you can
make all sorts of beautiful effects that
actually look earthly with something
that is built in math and I think that
is just super cool so I'm showing you
all of that to let you know that the web
has so much potential and we've only hit
the tip of the iceberg there's so many
things that we can do without
sacrificing performance without
sacrificing engagement without
sacrificing accessibility in fact making
accessibility better so even all
technologies by recombining them and by
thinking about them in a different way
and by thinking about our users we can
actually make the web be performant and
beautiful I do these web animation
workshops with Val head we you know go
around and teach people workshops so if
you want us to come near you
you can there's like a thing on our site
where you can let us know I think we're
gonna go to San Francisco next year and
also Europe and stuff so check that out
and I'm also writing an SVG animation
book this is not the cover of that book
this was my friend trolling me I don't
have the man blog animal I that's not
even my last name I do have a fancy
chicken though this the early release
for this book is coming out in a few
weeks I think so chapters one through
six and then the rest will come out
sometime in March I believe so we'll
we'll kind of keep going with these
early releases thank you for having me